everyone is talking about the Miami
Heats culture and Kevin Love hugging
Gabe Vincent last night is a perfect
example of it the shot clock was winding
down Vincent was wide open just chilling
honestly and Caleb missed him and passed
it to Max juice instead struce drew a
foul so it wasn't a massive deal but
love and Vincent were out there
reminding everyone that it is basketball
and it's not brain surgery mistakes do
happen a lot of Twitter was absolutely
loving the wholesome moment between the
two of them but then there are people
like Jeff Van Gundy who wanted
absolutely none of it this is what he
had to say I mean that's a little bit
dramatic just for missing a guy though
no we gotta hug it out now come on man